[Musique]
comme tous les mercredis après-midi
maman soit en mai ses enfants promenades
et comme tous les mercredis après-midi
le marchand de glaces est au rendez vous
mais les papiers et les bâtons on
n'hésite pas par terre évidemment après
avoir mangé une glace
on a une petite soit au nom pas les
boîtes par terre encore une fois
[Musique]
ce qui est de chocolat ça vous plaît ils
sont toujours aussi sale ses enfants the
wind tient bon et bien puisque ça leur
appartient
on va leur rapporter mois mais qu'a fait
sam est il possible être aussi sale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
printemps soit pour une fois qu'il n'a
rien fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais cela rappelle quelque chose à ma
montjoie et oui tout cela vous
appartient les seuls coupables c'est
vous tous vas t'en sors de ta cachette
et vient tout expliquer allez j'y tiens
on suit les nous on va vous montrer
[Musique]
en effet c'est tout simple il suffit de
déposer des poubelles
voyons ce que vont faire ces oies
gourdon et toc
ah bravo à fond
[Musique]
on continue c'est bien et voilà un petit
geste et tout est propre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez on recommence avec tout le monde
on va lancer une opération
lille propres bravo à tout le temps et
merci
[Musique]
et